ces manuels macron a décidé de convoquer
un nouveau conseil de défense à à
l'elysée qui a lieu en ce moment même
bonjour alexandra renard vous vous
trouvez devant l'elysée pour france24
nouveau conseil de défense donc après
plusieurs décisions prises par la france
et par la communauté internationale ces
derniers jours en réaction à cette
invasion russe en ukraine
puis effectivement emmanuel macron
préside actuellement un conseil de
sécurité national consacré à la
situation sur l'ukraine il
s'entretiendra ensuite avec le premier
ministre c'est une continuité à ce
conseil de défense suite à celui qui
s'est déroulé samedi dernier 26 février
au cours duquel ont été prise de grandes
décisions des décisions importantes
notamment pour la france qui a décidé de
renforcer son aide à l'ukraine en
passant par de l'équipement de défense
et de durcir ses sanctions notamment en
visant la plateforme interbancaire swift
et puis ensuite ont suivi ces grands la
décision des sanctions occidentales très
forte celle de bannir les médias russes
comment russia today est également au
spoutnik et interdire l'espace aérien à
l'ensemble des compagnies russes et des
avions russes de bloquer toutes les
transactions de la banque centrale russe
et surtout c'est une première en europe
l'envoi d'avions de chasse dans l'union
européenne a débloqué pour la première
fois de son histoire 450 millions
d'euros pour équiper l'ukraine d'armes
létales qui lui seront fournies ensuite
le président de république à 15h recevra
salomé sous rage billy c'est la
présidente de la géorgie pour discuter
une de stabilité régionale dans le
contexte de la guerre en ukraine et à
17h30 il sera en vision aux conférences
acte de nombreux chefs d'état et de
gouvernement l'allemagne le canada les
etats-unis l'italie le japon la pologne
la roumanie et des représentants des
institutions européennes et de l'otan et
enfin ce soir ce sera un dîner de
travail auquel prendra part le président
de la république un dîner avec lequel il
discutera avec les représentants
industriels européens en présence du
chancelier olaf scholz et de la
présidente de la commission pour sous la
forme d'un live vous savez également
suite à tous ces entretiens qui
diplomatique cas auquel a pris part
emmanuel macron et qu'il a souvent
conduit des décisions ont été prises la
france portera désormais un projet de
résolution au conseil de sécurité des
nations unies et elle appellera avant
tout un cessez le feu